[Musique]
bienvenue chez monnet l'un des leaders
de la chaussette de sport en france
trois cent mille paires fabriqués par an
sur ces machines des métiers à tisser de
haute technologie doté de plusieurs
centaines d'aiguilhe le coeur de lusine
c'est là que tout se joue
tout est automatique on a quand même
beaucoup de réglages fins et cela fait
partie aussi notre savoir-faire par les
techniciens qui sont là pour veiller à
ce que la maille soit bien bien tricoté
vu qu'il n'y ait pas de dépôt chaque
jour ils ne sont que trois pour
surveiller l'ensemble de la production
un poste stratégique ce fut bonne chez
de contrôler les chaussettes qui tombe
et je sens qu est ce que vous regardez
bien précisément bateau que quelque
chose est en entière
l'eau de saint simon trottier si on n'a
pas réglé si certains gestes restent
inchangés depuis près de 90 ans et la
création de l'entreprise
les chaussettes sont aujourd'hui conçu
en 3d sur ordinateur chaque année de
nouvelles collections voit le jour en
une journée on peut avoir fait le modèle
et ça peut marcher tout de suite ou des
fois il faut revenir un petit peu
plusieurs fois dessus rechange et des
des zones
parce qu'après on va faire les essais
tricotage et puis les techniciens vont
me dire balle en fait ça va pas bien
donc il faut il faut à la fois juste et
pour que quand on va à industrialiser le
produit que tout se passe bien aussi des
prototypes qui seront peut-être utilisé
par l'équipe de france de ski nordique
en 2014 lors de sa victoire aux jeux
olympiques de sotchi monnaie équipés
ainsi le biathlète martin fourcade
une reconnaissance pour les 23 salariés
de l'entreprise et l'attention qu'il
porte à chaque détail
mais les chaussettes par 2 et je regarde
s'il ya des défauts s'il ya des trous
quelque part des fils à couper si les
chaussettes a sans trop petit trop
grande
si c'est bien le talon est bien fait ça
prouve que on travaille bien nous les
français qu'on a quand même dû savoir
faire confirmé depuis 2010 est le
nouveau produit phare de monnaie
c'est la chaussette de ski équipés de
gel en silicone elle prévient des
douleurs au tibia fréquente chez les
skieurs succès immédiat des dizaines de
milliers de paires vendues via sur le
futur de l'entreprise
c'est une innovation qui permet nous
différencier de tous nos autres
concurrents d
très grosses sociétés étrangères
essentiellement européennes ou
américaines et qui n'ont pas ces
produits là donc lorsque l'on veut
percer sur un marché étranger
eh bien il faut faire une preuve de
notre capacité à amener quelque chose de
différent avec deux millions et demi de
chiffre d'affaires l'an passé monnet se
porte bien
pour les sportifs la marque est synonyme
de qualité
c'est un produit qu'on va acheter sur du
long terme cette chaussette on va mettre
un prix un petit peu plus élevé puisque
cette fabrication française
là on se retrouvera dans le temps c'est
que votre chaussettes en laine en
acheter trois dans l'année on a su très
qu'une dans l'année à l'avenir monnaies
veut rayonner à l'international
notamment sur le marché chinois des
sports de montagne en plein
développement
[Musique]